Hello friends I wanted to quickly share with you a
new History Channel I made called the History Zone
this is where I upload historical videos that fall
outside of the 1800s but I might put a few 1800s
videos up there as well so take a look when you
get a chance now Wyatt Earp has been a mysterious
figure in history there is not much documentation
on him, there are no videos of him speaking,
no audio recordings and so the following video
that you're about to see where the famous movie
director John Ford speaks about knowing Wyatt
Earp is what I believe to be the only video where
anybody who actually knew the legendary Lawman
in real life speaks about it and if any of you
out there know of any video or audio of anybody
else who knew Wyatt Earp and talks about it,
please let us know in the comments but I do
believe that at this time this is the only one
that exists so let's go ahead and get to it the
date of the recording is sometime in 1970 or 1971.
you remember the gunfight in the O.K. Corral
in Clementine? Surely. I'd seen it a couple
of times I mean the other other versions.
how did you uh come to stage it the way
you did? had you heard Earp himself tell the
story? yeah as I've told you, you know we've
reminisced about this many times. When Wyatt
Earp retired as a lawman Henry, as you know
he went to some little town north of Pasadena.
Now his wife was a very devout religious woman
and a couple of times a year she'd go to these
religious conventions in Utah and Eastern Arizona
and Wyatt would get on the streetcar and go up
to Universal City and join us. We became quite
friendly and I didn't know anything about the O.K.
Corral at the time, but Harry Carey knew about it,
and he asked Wyatt and Wyatt described the
fight fully exactly the way that you did it.
As a matter of fact he drew it out on paper
a sketch of the entire thing and that's a...
Wyatt said I was not a good shot. I'd hit close
to a man and that's exactly what you did [Music]
thank you
[Music]